anata no chichioyada ho Kirino Oh Madero
q --i o TK t ho curry no Oh muy macho
Carrera
oh [ __ ] subbu sir cetera
hm I see
ah what ah welcome to the new class on
pranking your top high school
thank you what's your name bro bro bro
tato my name is Brett 8o Rotato could it
be yes
my father once attended YouTube high
school I intend to follow his footsteps
your father was a brave man he died here
many centuries ago
I intend to climb the wall of dicks just
like once he did ha ha ha ha ha the
knave nests of the young very well we
shall see what talent you have you ready
for your first prank yes yes I am
well then follow me
mmm mmm ah here we are
you see that old lady over there oh sure
yes yes Jessie here know what I want you
to do mr. prank the [ __ ] out of that
[ __ ] I'll be filming our hands but I
can't just disrupt an innocent person
kind of [ __ ] would do that just for
personal views and gains I don't care if
my father did it
that's not my path I just want to be a
potato I just want to be a potato
they let potatoes in the palm these days
back in my day we were to skin them so
that's it Hey ladies
aah take this
Oh
ah oh my god
oh my god I think I killed her oh just
to brag Hank we need to get her to a
hospital
I think she's dead bro is this a prank
bro it's just a prank
what's filming at the cameras right
there
seriously she's dead she's dead yes I
killed her but it was just a prank I
know but she's yet but it would but it
was but I was just a prank
yes but this is real she's totally dead
let's get out of here before the cops
comes
what remember well that was a close one
you're ready for your next prank no I'm
seriously emotionally hurt and I think I
might tell table very well then bring in
my girlfriend this is my fake girlfriend
you're what I mean my real girlfriend
she's real this is this is real it's
just not fake it's not real well I'm
confused
is it real now this is a real prank it's
not fake we're gonna do a prank it's
real it's not real its fake I mean it's
real it's totally real this prank is
real isn't that right oh my girlfriend
boobs so we're just gonna center the
whole prank around that yeah that makes
sense
you ready it's real she has no idea
what's gonna happen
this is totally real you film it okay
I'll I'll oh yeah you're ready totally
real girlfriend that's probably yes
today
it's just a prank bro calm down hey
break it up with you ah this is awkward
it's like my seventh girlfriend this
week and that's cool
yeah yes it is cool I'm cool right I
swear I'm cool I have this glasses and
this this hat
and I and I Drive a Lamborghini
because I made the money from the videos
but still my heart is so empty I will
never know true love because my
personality is full of [ __ ] why does no
one love me is it because my mouth look
like a caterpillar or weird-ass rainbow
yes that must be it
I'm empty on the inside and dark on the
outside sounded racist but I wasn't
intended that way
sorry but what the [ __ ] are you talking
about
but brah do you see this [ __ ] bored
hoverboard do you see this hoverboard do
you think it's cheap it's like 300
pounds do you want to [ __ ] cheeky
nandos up your ass
alright let's just do the next prank
follow me buh-buh-buh-buh uh-huh brah
here we are and together this is where
poor people live you know yes yes I am
aware we film here because poor people
they react more I don't know what it is
but more reactions means more views I
would trust me trust me I would know
about that [ __ ]
your father must be proud to see you
make it this far in the cracking yes I
still intend to make him proud very well
for the final prac we will burn down
this homeless man's house but if he's
homeless than well let's do it I'll be
filming
we will be where we will be but but but
that that's my house oh just a prank
you got pranked where's Ashton oh you
got put you got pranked but I you're a
little [ __ ] it's a prank bro it's just
a prank bro it's just a prank the camera
is right there brother cameras right
there that's just a prank
that's just a break don't you like
bro I guess you don't like pranks I
stole your car just a prank bro I [ __ ]
your wife just a prank bro I gave you
aids just your prank bro
it ruined your life just a prank bro
can't you people understand
it's just gone
Oh
that's why
it's just a prank bro
it's just a prank the cameras right
there
the cameras right there
just a friend
don't you like Briggs bro I guess you
don't like pranks
I got you fired just a prank bro I've
burned down
choose the red bro I hate your children
ders to pray what that wasn't a prank
though can't use people understand that
it's just comedy as [ __ ] fine that's
why it's okay
it's just a prank
it's just a break the cat
the cameras right hey Frank on fire
is your name
natural
big deai
that's a break job
to you